Kemba Walker  smart smart at the buzzer goodness  gracious  big-time  oh yeah names you know we said back up  up and send them home oh boy  what a finish here in Sacramento  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  last season against Boston  it was Gordon Hayward who shot did fall  another look how close was this man look  at what's not homes get up and that  thing is on the rim and it just decides  it is Sunday and it is not the Celtics  day well done by the Kings ear Halloran  forest please drop no goals that biggest  one in the air for the Sacramento Kings  they beat the ten-in-one  Boston Celtics and that man Buddy hield  not only did he score 35 they had some  big time defensive plays down the  stretch for Sacramento how about it fall  another look how close was this man look  at what's not homes get up and that  thing is on the rim and it just decides  it is Sunday and it is not the Celtics  day well done by the Kings ear hollers  for it please drop no gold